jour après jour les vitrines du musée du
septennat se vident les cadeaux reçus
pendant sa présidence par françois
mitterrand rejoignent des boîtes et des
caisses une opération qui demande aux
grandes précautions on voit cette
défense d'éléphant lors cette défense
d'éléphant l'oubli qu'elle fait dix
kilos donc entre 10 à 15 kg ce sont des
éléments qui change c'est lourd très
fragile
les pros la lumière voilà donc il faut
adapter à chaque objet vivement les
espaces d'exposition sont fermées au
public depuis le 1er septembre
ici tout sera transformée au cours des
prochains mois des salles jusqu'au
extérieur les musée du septennat et du
costume était jusqu'ici séparer le
nouveau projet les réunira en aménageant
ses jardins et en ajoutant une grande
galerie vitrée qui sera l'emblème de
cette cité muséal le château chinon qui
se revendique capitale du morvan et
qu'il est dans l'esprit de tous avait
également vocation à accueillir un
équipement culturel fort d'où l'idée de
rouvrir le musée sur le centre-ville et
de favoriser la circulation du public
accueilli sur château chinon et pour que
les retombées soient soit optimisé la
nouvelle entrée se fera au coeur de la
ville depuis la maison du morvan au
total l'investissement sera de près de
10 millions d'euros et les habitants
espèrent que le projet est de
redynamiser la ville non mais c'est bien
oui si ça peut attirer les touristes
pourquoi pas
bien sûr parce que sinon la ville va
mourir s'il n'y a plus rien quand ses
vacances chez quand même à une ville
morte
il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde quand
même c'est grâce au lycée qu'il ya de la
vie dans
en attendant costumes et objets seront
stockés et en partie restauré une
nouvelle scénographie sera ensuite mise
en place complété par des galeries
numérique la cité muséal devrait ouvrir
ses portes au public en 2022